I do have a surprise for you because I
wanted to show you the mistake I'm not
fat I just thought hello
joining me in studio today is Jim
Gaffigan who has not one but two movies
at the LA Film Festival very exciting
let's start with American dreamer okay
so this is like I think people mostly
associate you as comedy but then you
kind of do take on a lot of these like
really exciting dark roles for you so
what was it about this part that that
you loved well I I really responded to
the script because I felt like it
captured what it's like when you live
through a series of bad luck and how you
kind of have to deal with it
everything's gonna be okay I just want
the money it's pretty surprising good
twists and turn
so even when I read it I was very
surprised because you think it's gonna
be oh it's this movie but it's not that
is what ages right and so you have to
watch it to the end because there's a
couple moments we were like oh wow and
and the way it was directed you know you
know he also wrote it with someone they
knew exactly what they wanted to do it
was not done it's a very low-budget kind
of dark story for people that love dark
stories right and then you have the
second film also premiering at LA Film
Festival which is you can choose your
family yes I play the father it's it's
about a teenager who is dealing with a
rather strict father in the early 90s
and what is revealed is that the father
played by me has two families and not
good not good not good don't recommend
so but the thing that was fun about that
role was attempting and this it's in the
script but attempting to humanize this
monstrous choice that this characters
made and it is a comedy but it's
obviously a really kind of absurd topic
and you know we were shooting
and like a house that we were shooting
in just by half a you know by
coincidence they're like yeah a guy that
lived there they pointed in another
house had two families look at used I
mean now we're in the internet age where
you can kind of Google things right like
that but it used to be on a common I
guess that's correct I don't know
anything about anything else besides I
have two families I don't know you do
play such an array of array of roles and
you have five kids right is there a role
that you could take where your kids
would think is like the ultimate role
where they think you were like the
coolest guy ever oh my god well if I was
in a superhero movie yeah I mean I you
know Hotel Transylvania 3 like being the
villain in that my my five year old I
brought him to the theater to see it and
he was when he kind of figured out that
that was me as Van Helsing
it was the first time he was ever
impressed by me otherwise I was just
some guy that competed for food you know
but it's yeah so like being in a
superhero movie would probably really
impress them but I don't know you know I
feel like I'm eventually you know
everyone's parents are kind of and
embarrassed a source of embarrassment
apparently yeah so I'll lose them all
but you know right now they like me but
then they come back hopefully so you do
incorporate your family into your stand
up a lot do any of your kids show
interest in like kind of contributing to
some of the bits are they showing any of
that there is you know it's weird cuz I
write with my wife and so will
occasionally be at the dinner table and
there'll be a discussion of something
and it will indirectly lead to you know
like yeah I'll mention but I can't
there's definitely been examples of my
14 year old making some observation
which will which is brilliant right well
that'll turn into a joke look I think I
was doing I did a show in Ireland and
she talked about line dried clothes how
everyone in Ireland
drives their clothes and how after three
days they're still wet so I took that
and that's part of a larger piece of my
new show well I do have a surprise for
you
because I wanted to show you the mistake
it's not a steak but I do have ETS very
first interview with you oh my god to
show you yes friends welcome to New York
it's very good I was robbed last week
and it was all right somebody they
attacked me and they shaved my head
actually I had a full head of hair and
these guys broke in my apartment shaved
my head when I was sleeping and I don't
appreciate that
they said you look too much like John
Tesh and they shaved my head saying what
happened it's I mean that was over 70
years ago 70 years that's that's so
weird
I'm not a fan of seeing myself yeah and
fan of the surprise well that's also I
mean it's a very nice surprise
but it is also like like how much it's
like I literally just started gaining
weight right after that with you it's
just like how much weight can I gain by
2008 that was the goal after that but
that was before five kids yeah yeah I
believe in the interview you said you
were dating Christie Brinkley and
Christine Baranski and Sandra Bullock
yeah I was dating my wife and reality
and during that time period and then you
know everything changed yeah and this is
by the way this is prosthetic this is
nice this just helps some of the bits
what advice would you give year 2000
June Gaussian wow that's a great
question
I'm a great interview I would say work
on the things you can control right
right
I'm in the entertainment industry is I
know here we are on at or at a zit this
that the entertainment industry is
brutal it's brutal but you have to work
on the things you can control and
and so I I feel like whenever I find
myself frustrated it usually means I'm
trying to control something that I have
no control over
right yeah you know and that's why I
love stand-up because I you know I can
write it I can go and perform it and I
don't have to worry and that's why I
appreciate the opportunity to have roles
like American dreamer and you can choose
your family because I know that you know
skinny Jim Gaffigan would have given his
right arm to do him and it only took 20
years for it to happen
[Music]